thank you
this tiny strip of land in Eastern
Europe is being called NATO's dangerous
spot it's known as The savalki Gap
it forms the border between NATO members
Poland and Lithuania and lies in between
two Russian military strongholds
military strategists say this sparsely
populated area with hills forests and
small villages will be a prime target if
Russia decides to attack NATO territory
Poland and Lithuania are worried about
this scenario becoming reality as
fighters from the Wagner mercenary group
arrive on their doorstep in Belarus
so here's what's at stake if the savalki
Gap comes under attack
the savaki Gap is around 60 miles long
and separates Poland to the west and
Lithuania to the east to its North West
lies kalinograd a chunk of Russian
territory with a number of military
bases
it's also home to Russia's Baltic naval
fleet and its only port on the Baltic
Sea that doesn't freeze up in the winter
but it's not linked to the Russian
mainland
the most direct routes from kaliningrad
to Russia will be through the savaki Gap
via Russia's neighbor and Ally Belarus
by the Russian president Alexander
luccheshenker allowed Moscow to use his
country as a base to launch the
full-scale invasion of Ukraine
military analysts say Russia could
attack from two ends of the savalki Gap
with soldiers from kalinograd and forces
advancing through Belarus which would
leave NATO members Lithuania Latvia and
Estonia isolated Moscow would also gain
more access to the Baltic Sea a crucial
Gateway for commercial shipping NATO has
few options to defend its Baltic members
by land they'll have to send in
reinforcements through Poland to
Lithuania by crossing the savalki Gap
only two highways and a train line
connect Poland and the Baltic states
that means this narrow strip of land
could become congested with troops and
military hardware the stakes were raised
even higher in recent months
first fighters from the Wagner mercenary
group started relocating to Belarus
after aborting a mutiny in Russia in
June
then according to Belarusian television
Wagner truth began training by the
Russian soldiers just three miles from
the Polish border Poland's prime
minister says the situation is becoming
dangerous mommy information
who also responded by sending up to 10
000 extra troops to guard its border
with Belarus Poland and Lithuania have
also closed some of their border
crossings with their Eastern neighbor
NATO has tried to strengthen its
defenses in the region
multinational battle groups with around
1 000 troops have been set up in each of
the Baltic states
large-scale drills have taken place in
the area close to the savalki Gap as a
way to show NATO's readiness
the Baltic states and Poland have also
ramped up defense spending they have all
vowed to spend three percent of their
GDP per year on defense more than NATO's
two percent targets the leaders of
Lithuania Latvia and Estonia want NATO
forces to be stationed in the region
permanently
in the meantime NATO's defense
capabilities in the area strengthened
with two new members Finland and Sweden
this opens up a gateway to reach the
baltics by sea and air boosting any
potential defense on land Finland and
Sweden's militaries also add hundreds of
warplanes tanks and tens of thousands of
soldiers to the alliance
analysts say this makes a Russian
invasion even more costly Finland and
Sweden's integration means kalinograd is
effectively encircled by NATO any attack
by Russia could leave the exclaim
vulnerable to isolation and blockade by
the alliance
analysts believe Russia is unlikely to
launch an armed attack on the sivaki Gap
while it has his hands full with Ukraine
polish opposition neither Donald Tusk
who's campaigning to become the next
prime minister accused the government of
using the Wagner threats to stoke fear
ahead of October's election but Poland's
government denies this
still NATO's Eastern members say
Wagner's presence on their doorstep
remains a security risk that's why they
want to make sure the savalki Gap is
well defended to deter any potential
aggression from Russia